amateur shutterbug since the 70s now
he's selling his prints and giving the
proceeds to help young Canadian
entrepreneurs earlier today he walked me
through his exhibit 40 years of
photography it's at first Canadian place
here in Toronto so here's the inside
scoop on some of his prints
so why photography for you how when did
you get interested
well back in 1980 I had a career as an
editor on a steam Beck I worked for
hockey net in Canada for a company I
started called special men television my
work was in a darkroom cutting film for
the Olympics working on Hockey Night in
Canada I was always interested in
pursuing a career as a photographer so I
always had a camera with me I've taken
thousands of images over the years
wherever I've traveled TV is a career
and my business career is taking me
everywhere and this is a collection of
my 40-year journey and images from all
these different places I've been to it's
very difficult to curate a show like
this but when we took that theme all of
a sudden it came together so there's 40
years of photography here and obviously
that's gonna be a whole range of not
just your experiences but also different
types of cameras what's the kind of
first camera you had you're really old
so it's really a brownie
well the first camera I could afford was
a Soviet made Zenit II it was very
inexpensive it had limitations in fact I
have a photograph of it here in the
exhibit and it was the first time I ever
had an SLR which you shoot through the
lands a 35 millimeter and I took my very
first images of that as I could afford
it I always upgraded my my you know
photography equipment today I have many
many different cameras I shoot with
Hasselblad's Leica's all kinds of
different technology but it's remarkable
in this show some of my in other
people's view my best work comes from my
earliest lowest-cost cameras which shows
you photography is an eclectic art you
just don't know when you're capturing an
image how great it will be as time
passed do you have a favorite out of
these images here obviously this is
distilling down a lot of your work of
the ones you've chosen to show here or
there's something
really jump out for you there is one
that I took decades ago in an Armenian
Church using the light of candles it's
right over here and what I like about
this image is it's been reborn in a
different way using technology these
candles provide a very very limited
light and this was not digital at the
time this was taken with Triax
black-and-white film and because of its
limitations there's two characters in
here a face on the far left and one on
the right which is very haunting that I
could never pull from the negative
decades ago using today's digital
technology rescanning the images and
working with some great technicians
there's almost 20 people involved in
this show we were able to find that
person existing in the civil nitro he
was there before we we could we knew he
was there but we couldn't pull him we
couldn't pull him out and and we were
able to do it using this remarkable new
technology and and I think now this
image is completely different than what
I envisioned if I showed you the
original one converses this this face is
very haunting and actually the most
interesting part of it it's this kind of
attention in the image is his face
exactly so which is why I find this work
so interesting because it's a
combination of what happened that moment
decades ago and technology that allowed
it to be reborn you have I mean we look
at kind of the range of stuff you've got
here when you're out you're wandering
and this is obviously kind of an iconic
iconic piece this piece the curator who
hung this Peter he'll this is his
favorite piece because he's of this
generation this bust was stolen after he
died you cannot find it anymore it's a
very rare piece and it's a it captures
that moment when Morrison's bust which
is somewhere on this earth but nobody
knows where it's been stolen these are
very recent these were taken this year
in st. Barts I call this woman on chains
I love the soft woman on these hard
chains and this is just a whimsical
picture that happened this summer on
Nantucket the lifeguard actually was
taking a bite out of a sandwich I didn't
Photoshop his head out of it and the
more you look at it the more it raises
questions all kinds of naughty questions
oh you have to go there I have to
because people have told me about this
image now and I've had lots of emails
about it saying it's one of their
favorite in the exhibit did you take it
knowing
that he was gonna bend over and take the
bite out of the sandwich I started to
see it happen when because he was eating
the sandwich repeatedly and I thought
this is interesting yeah
his head's gone and and I I only had
that one frame that I was able to get it
but it was it and I just loved the
technology now this is a metallic paper
called flex you can almost touch that
wood yes technology and photography now
is so remarkable these are our Kaiba
museum prints they're very expensive to
make but I'm going to be selling them at
this exhibit and what are you doing with
the money when why are you doing this
I'm on to support an initiative that the
CBC is launching to support with me
teenage entrepreneurs so you'll be able
to go to the website starting October
23rd put a three-minute video up there
tell me if you're in grade 11 or 12 why
you deserve $5,000 to start your
entrepreneurial journey and I'll write
you the check so that's what we're
promoting here and then I'm going to
take this exhibit across North America
staying on that theme all right let me
show you my favorite one please do this
one this has a very interpretive
provenance here's what happened it was
one of my first digital images and I
lost the original digital file
I had one paper image left of it weari
scanned it and now it's this thank you
very much Amanda